we're in the homestretch people yeah
that's right only 12 more days left in
this shopping season to pick the leader
of the free world if the polls are right
Hillary's well on her way to winning
this thing though my guess is that the
polls are going to tighten significantly
as we get closer to election day as they
almost always do also polls are just
polls at the end of the day and nobody
knows what will happen until Election
Day itself I've been saying this for a
while now but I'm guessing that many
people aren't publicly saying that
they're supporting Trump out of fear or
shame or public humiliation so the polls
might not be as accurate as pretty much
everyone is saying they are whether the
polls are right or wrong anything can
happen in the next 12 days and knowing
this election anything that can happen
will happen just wait for the Trump once
groped a donkey Hillary's being funded
by mr. burns headlines the day before
the election a few really interesting
storylines have taken root over the past
couple weeks on the Clinton front it's
pretty clear that there was some sort of
coordination with acts who conspired to
create violence at Trump rallies
regardless of who you're supporting in
this election I recommend taking a look
at the project veritas videos here on
YouTube while you should view them with
a skeptical eye because Andrew O'Keefe
of veritas obviously is no Hillary fan
the videos do appear to provide proof of
her campaign doing some seriously shady
stuff to paint Trump supporters in a
negative light and expose as much of
this manufactured violence as possible
to our lap dog media when you consider
the project veritas videos and add in
the continuing information WikiLeaks is
dropping about the hillary campaign
colluding with friendly sources in the
media as well as the DNC's rigging of
the primaries against Bernie it's pretty
clear that even the most ardent Hillary
supporter must acknowledge that there's
been major ethical if not legal
violations by her campaign on the Trump
front there are a whole slew of other
issues first the continuing allegations
of sexual assault surrounding Trump
though none of them have been proven
true yet while his words to billy bush
about grabbing women were crass words do
not equal action and until any of these
allegations are proven to be
true they remain just allegations
regardless of whether they are true or
not apparently we live in a quazy post
truth society where people get to decide
what's true depending on whether or not
they like the person this is a huge
problem because any of us could be
accused of anything I wish my friends on
the Left were a little more
understanding of this even when it's
politically expedient for them right now
to use innuendo to destroy Trump the
bigger concern here about Trump right
now is his rhetoric around the elections
being fixed you all know I'm no fan of
the mainstream media and I've
consistently called out the bad actions
of the Hillary campaign as I did just a
second ago however Trump's saying that
our elections are rigged before they
even happened and with no evidence is an
actual assault on our democratic system
for all of America's faults we've always
without exception had an easy transfer
of power from one administration to
another this transfer of power from
party to party has been a key to our
success as a nation for over 200 years
we accept the results of an election and
we put down the fight until the next one
while our elections themselves have had
issues just ask al gore in 2000 there
has been a respect for the process by
everyone who has run for the office
Trump is preemptively shredding this
contract we've always abided by
potentially laying the groundwork for
civil unrest and violence and guess what
when the Trump supporters are out there
on the streets protesting rightly or
wrongly watch how quickly the left will
be into the same state power they
usually decry in putting down those
protests true democracy must survive any
candidate whether you think that the
candidate is a crook or a narcissist by
the way I'm not making a false
equivalence here I think there are
wildly different reasons we should be
suspect of both Clinton and Trump
unfortunately these are the two were
left with and hopefully whichever of
them wins will prove me wrong either by
making us stronger together or by making
America great again my guest this week
is Hillary Rosen Hillary is a democratic
strategist often seen on CNN as well as
a partner skb Knickerbocker a strategy
and media relations firm Hilary knows
the media landscape and the Democratic
machine well and we're going to cover
all of the issues I've mentioned here
and many more I know that by just saying
demo
craddock some of you will automatically
dislike her and some of you will
automatically like her for those of you
in between which is undoubtedly the
fastest growing group in American
politics it's important to hear from all
sides and decide what you believe in as
I mentioned last week I see a new
political alignment happening right
before our eyes many classical liberals
conservatives and libertarians are
suddenly realizing we are at all each
other's enemies so regardless of whether
it's president Trump or President
Clinton we should be finding allies in
our fight to make America same again
you